if you've been paying attention in the
architecture industry you would have
noticed that archers
are making a huge comeback
what's going on guys my name is david
thomich and welcome back to the channel
firstly if you're new here
thank you so much for joining me on this
channel we talk all things architecture
and technology
today i'm going to be teaching you
exactly how i created this masterpiece
in
archicad 24. now like i already
mentioned archers are making a huge
comeback and they seem to be
becoming more and more popular with
apartment design
especially residential design here in
western australia
now arches and curves in general are
very complicated in archicad 24
they've never been the default setting
for any sort of architectural programs
and they've never been preferred really
by builders but
you have to stick with some of the
trends especially when you're trying to
stand out in portfolios and resumes and
things like that
so enough of my jibber jabbering let's
turn around for these two screens behind
me and get started with today's tutorial
okay so like always we're going to start
with the default template whatever you
guys have available to you
i'm going to be starting with the
australian select template because that
is the default for arcade 24
for me here in australia now arcade 25
is actually being announced next week so
i will be doing a video
specifically on archicad 25 as we
transition in
to the brand new era of archicad today's
tutorial is going to be predominantly
based on how we create beautiful arches
with windows but obviously we need to
draw our actual architecture first
so simply what we're going to do is
start with a slab tool
and press ctrl and the down arrow to
create our footings layer
now if you've seen any of my other
videos before you know i always start by
creating a footings layer at -172
so all we've done is just command down
or
control down whatever system you're on
and creating that footings layout so
let's start by clicking on this slab
tool here
clicking once drawing all the way across
pressing our tab button
and typing in 30 meters by 30 meters
now we have this massive square to start
off with
and we're not really going to be playing
with any of these sectional elevation
markers
in this video so we're going to click
them all ctrl d
and just simply click and move them away
so as you can see now we have our slab
we're going to start with our wall tool
we have an external wall
it doesn't really matter what we're
going to use for the wall we're not
focusing on construction details here or
anything we're predominantly focusing on
those beautiful arches
so if we draw once holding the shift
button we can draw a dead straight
square
all four ways around and we have our
square
if we come into this show 3d we'll see
that we've drawn a very
small very very small wall in fact it's
only 172 tall
and that's because it's linked to our
footings and ground floor
so if we open up the settings of the
wall by clicking control or command t
it opens up our settings and we have a
bit more freedom so our home story is
going to be the ground floor
and we're not actually going to link it
to anything i'm just going to make it
straight up
10 meters tall and there we go we have
our first wall and block created pretty
easily and pretty quickly
now this slab is way too low so i'm
going to change that to 172
lift it up so it reaches the edge of
our wall now just looking at this
straight away i think the proportions
are out for what we're trying to create
but that's good it means we can actually
go around and change a few bits and
pieces
so what we're going to do is click once
on this edge and drop that
back down to 15 meters drop that back
down to 15 meters
go control up come to our walls and do
the same thing
so it's ungrouped that i've just done
alt g control
g 15 meters in control
d 15 meters in and then i can hold
the control button and click away all of
these walls
so now if we come back to our 3d we'll
see the squares significantly smaller
and we're going to be able to start
drawing some arches
into this design so i'm thinking that
it's going to be a very simple
upside down glass panel here normal arch
panel here
wrapping around repeating that pattern
on all four sides
so overall it is a very very simple
design but it is a bit more complicated
to create in archicad
so let's start with the simple and most
basic window which is
the typical arched window now a quick
little break make sure you smash that
like
button to help with the youtube
algorithm i promise quick so back to it
with a typical arch window all we want
to do is go to the window tool
open up our window tool and start by
clicking
arch and straight away you can see we
have this arch top window 24 which we
can use as our default principle for
creating
that window as you know i hate these
orange lines so i always override them
straight to black so we don't have to
look at the orange
horrendousness that it does show as
default so
if we open up our window we can see
what's going on we can manipulate our
glass later on but let's just go to a
fixed
glass panel and start actually adjusting
the size
i think because we have a 15 meter wide
building we're probably going to have to
have
somewhere about 5 meters wide which also
means we're going to need a very very
tall arch to be able to compensate for
that
so let's go 10 or 10 meters is our
actual overall building height so let's
go
uh maybe seven and a half meters and see
how it looks so let's now start with
this
and move on as we require so if we drop
our first little window in
right here clicking once clicking again
to let go
it creates our first arched window now i
do want to
set that down to ground level and it's
still too small in my opinion
so i'm going to bring that up to about 9
meters and i'm also going to make it
i believe seven and a half meters wide
probably a little bit too much so let's
make it six
meters wide okay so once we've created
our first arch window we want to go into
the settings and actually define what we
want it to look like
so first of all i don't really want this
main sash
coming across here so we are going to
get rid of that transom up the top
and secondly i wanted to have some sort
of grid throughout
because it is a very large piece of
glass and something like that would be
horrendously expensive
and almost unfeasible in real life so i
think i'm going to go something
like the default 3x3 grid but making
them
100 by 100 millions
and going all the way throughout our
frame as well is quite thin we'd want it
to be a lot thicker than that
so we're going to just manipulate these
settings here so let's make it 100 thick
100 thick and just 100 thick for the
purposes of argument nothing
really else now if we click ok we'll get
our
default window created it is quite thick
and chunky but it is also quite nice
so what i'm going to do next is just
change the materiality of it
i really want to focus on getting this
window right because you'll understand
why in a second creating an upside down
arch window is a huge
complication in archicad and we want to
get the first window 100 correct
so let's change the materials on this
window let's say we want to make this
i don't know we'll paint it titanium
white for the time being and we'll make
sure all those settings
are identical so it's painted titanium
white the pen tool is going to be black
we'll change all of them to black by
default so nothing comes across
clicking ok and we have our nice
white painted window opening here now
just a quick interlude before we go any
further
i have recently just made the
architecture group
chat on discord completely free for
everybody to join so if you want to join
discord chat where we talk about all
things architecture
these videos in general and just discuss
and help each other out as
individuals professionals students
architects designers
anybody in the industry feel free to
join the group chat down below
there is also a patreon link just below
that
if you want a copy of any of the
archicad files
that i have created now this is where it
gets a little bit controversial
and there is a magnitude of different
ways of doing this you can do it by
downloading different libraries you can
do it by downloading different windows
but this is the simplest and easiest way
i've been able to find that you can do
it in archicad 24
without going outside of the standard
parametrics that are installed in the
program
unfortunately you can't just simply go
into these settings and
flip this arch from the top to the
bottom so what we're going to do is come
back to our ground floor
we're going to move this window let's
say we'll move it
500 millimeters from the corner we'll
take it copy it by clicking
command d and then tapping the command
button again
command d once more 500 millimeters from
the corner
we're left with two meters so i believe
if we push that another 500
push that another 500 we'll have a
symmetrical
gap between all so one meter one meter
one meter now this is again where it
gets controversial and
there's a million one ways to do it but
this is just the quickest and easiest
way i've found for you guys
so select the window you want to be the
opposite way
right click convert to morph it's going
to give you a whole bunch of errors
we're just going to click ok
i'm going to mute my sound so you don't
hear that beautiful sound again
open up the settings and we're just
going to change
all these lines to black there we go we
have an identical window on
this side we're going to click on that
window command
e to open up the rotate tool flip it all
the way
upside down and we're just going to
simply make sure by going back into our
ground floor plan
that it is in that exact location where
it was before
so command d to be able to move it and
adjust it back into our 3d window
clicking on it once more command d at
the very
top of that frame all the way to the top
of the building
and then we're going to highlight this
simple window opening and then simply
move it to the top of that wall
same as our window but what we're going
to have to do next
is simply drag it halfway up to where
that arch is
copy that down all the way to the bottom
and readjust this shape that we've just
created
so re-selecting our simple opening tool
clicking on that once more
we're going to start adjusting the
openings so what we really want
is around opening 24 clicking ok
it's going to give us our nice round
opening let's drag that all the way up
so we can actually see it
and make it significantly wider so it
starts cutting our window we do want to
drag the center of this window
to the start of our last one and
extending
the size of our circle all the way to
the bottom so we know
where we need to be now finally we just
simply extend the top
as much as we need to to be able to line
that up perfectly
and there we have it we have our first
form of this
upside down arch and to be able to
replicate that around
the side of this building is relatively
simple
instead of going around copying these
windows what i'm going to do is select
these three walls
delete them copy this by clicking
control d
control again rotate once selecting all
rotating twice so now we have our 15 by
15
square with our wrapping arches and our
beautiful flow
now obviously this would need some sort
of roof so we'll just slap on a concrete
roof by duplicating that across
i'm going to select both of those for
the simplicity of this
and the floor it'll probably be some
sort of concrete so let's just make it
concrete light 23
we'll do the exact same thing with these
four walls selecting all four
coming into the outside let's paint some
concrete throughout
concrete light 23 okay
and there we go we have our upside down
arch design anyway that's all for me
today guys thank you so much for
watching i hope you enjoyed the video
i hope you learned something new in
archicad 24 today that you didn't know
before
if you did make sure you smash that
subscribe button down below and don't
forget about the like button
the like button truly helps with the
youtube algorithm
so smashing it will only help more
people find this channel and will only
motivate me
to keep growing this channel and keep
growing this community like i said
that's all for me today so i will see
you
next monday